steven strasburg five and one career
against the reds in 10 starts well this
season so far stevens fastball has been
up to 92 miles per hour he features his
curveball about 30 percent of the time
suarez the third straight game in the
lead-off spot three for nine with a home
run
in that lead off position
send in the air
fairly deep right center field that's
got some carry and that's gone baby hey
eugenio suarez a spark at the start as
he goes oppo again his 11th home run and
the reds on the board it's one to
nothing
that's the best lead off hitter i've
ever seen
this side of ricky
henderson
staying with this one staying behind it
oh what a great feeling that must be for
suarez
you saw shogo
akiyama on deck and there's strasbourg
with a hitter lunging for the ball tyler
stevenson now over seven
against the nats two outs sonny gray
hits the start for the reds on the hill
and gray in the month of may a two seven
eight earned run average he comes off a
quality start his numbers on the season
from western and southern so the batting
average at 282 the on base percentage
fine at 396. the gnats are just looking
for extra base hits from juan soto
that's a rocket to center from soto
stayed back beautifully
on the 79 mile an hour curveball
and juan soto now has been on base five
times in this series and here's josh
bell who's two for 12 against him
shift is on 2-1
lifted bell
frustrated suarez
makes the catch carl went 1-4 in the
first game
got his hit yesterday
two outs full count
runner goes
and that's strike three
sonny gray the backwards k of schwarber
he has a greiten
gray strands a man
and his lead off homer tonight has the
reds on top
swan gonna miss why not
if you're reading swings
he stays with it and that's strikeout
number two
jesse winker hit on the back foot by a
curveball first time
he's heading for some career numbers
this year and we've also seen him go to
left but schwarber is going to rob him
to his right kyle schwarber continues to
play very good left field for the next
great play by kyle one of the tough
parts about making this play as a left
fielder is that the fans don't realize
the row of lights from the grandstand
actually come into play good job by him
sliding making the play look at the
concentration there
nice
yup give him credit
that was very good here's naquin who
lined out to stevenson in center first
time
swing and a miss
a little crackle on that fastball at 94.
strasbourg throwing lots of hooks and i
would think that heater played a lot
quicker than it looked
so now the second time through begins
with trey turner
a little looping line drive toward short
on one hop it's fielded by farmer to his
left the throw to first is too late
oh the blazing speed of turner legs out
ahead
a soft line drive that farmer played on
one bounce got rid of it quickly but it
was still too late with turner legging
out the infield base head that'll give
the nationals
soto a chance now
well he had the
turner burners turned on
and basically beats out a somewhat
routine play
i know it's not like farmer took a lot
of time he got rid of it quick he
fielded it well
turner lunging for that swing got a good
break out of the box and was at full
speed one stride in
so here's soto at a base hit to center
in the first
turner is a track start to second
grounded easy play
just a broken bat infield hit this
inning one nothing still
shogo akiyama ground ball to garcia
right side first time up ending the
first inning with a runner aboard
swang gonna miss on the curveball and he
had to hit her all over the place with
that effort
strikeout number four
kyle farmer hit the ball fairly well
first time lined out to juan soto to
start the second
popped him up
jan gomez having a look steven strasberg
has set down eight consecutive
cincinnati reds cal schwarber called out
on strikes first time
oh nice play by gray he is on tonight
he's in the moment right there
and starlin castro is next
sonny gray is just dead on
he is dominating and dealing up one
number
so with one out here on the top of the
fifth it's sunny gray and it creates
more spin ball up the middle off the
foot of strasbourg and sunny gray has a
one-ounce single it's his first hit of
the year here's the first baseman
blandino how about a strikeout two down
steven strasberg number five the only
run of the game a eugenio suarez
just misses low
strike zone has been a little generous
for both teams and you could see the the
hesitation there from geno puts a runner
in scoring position and brings up jesse
winker
up the middle takes a weird skip into
center field a whip around third gray
scores
suarez over to third base the reds
expand the lead it's two nothing nothing
he is flied out and struck out
opposite way gets
down face hit that is fair suarez scores
all the way over to third base jesse
winker and rbi double for tyler naquin
and a two run ending the reds lead three
to nothing
most of the time
oh swaying it a miss
he spikes the breaking ball and still
gets the chase who goes what a clean
pick there by stevenson too
the unrelated andrew stevenson spells
his name differently
pay off strike three wow
sonny gray means business
five two hit headaches of shut apple
sonny gray is done
he went six scoreless the baton handed
to lucas sims he came in the other day
and took care of whatever problem the
nationals were causing with amir garrett
through four straight sliders and ended
up getting starlin castro to hit a
ground ball to end the ball game a
couple of saves to his credit
26 strikeouts in 17 innings he is
a hard guy to make contact with
big shift is on kyle schwarber has
struck out bounced to the pitcher
fastball strike three
lucas sims challenges schwarber goes
down looking and the reds are two outs
away
one out away luis garcia
one two
shot to right center on the sprint
[Applause]
shogo akiyama makes the catch and the
reds win it a combined two-hitter
they blank the nationals in d.c
and the reds take not only this game but
also the series
the road trip is off to a winning start